انقره هل ترى بان
ادبيات سنان اوغان اذا صح التعبير التي
خاض على اساسها هذه الانتخابات قد تضع
حواجز امام اعطائه اصوات لهذا الطرف او
لطرف اخر
نت
واضح اعتقدوا ان السنان اوران واضح الموقف
والناخب ايضا ان هو
فان
هم يعتبرون وجود الاكراد عنصره تهديد
على وحده تركيا فبالتالي لا يكتفون
بالاكراد بل يشملون ذلك ويوسعون الدائره
باعتبار اللاجئين المهاجرين
الذين عددهم حوالي 4.5 وكذلك الاجانب
الذين يبلغ ربما عددهم الاجمالي ثمانيه
ملايين يعتبرونهم عنصر
تهديد وبالتالي ان هؤلاء يتحدثون عن
القوميه التركيه الصافيه العنصريه ايضا
فبالتالي كلما هو يلح يعرفون جميع
التيارات القوميه المتطرفه هكذا تكون بها
شعارات وبالتالي بالداخل دائما
لديهم نظره سلبيه وبالتالي يعتبرون ان
الذين
ياتون من الخارج من الاجانب ايضا هم
يمثلون عنصر
تهديد وائل لا بعد ذلك فان هناك تطابق في
معظم الرؤى والمواقف في واقي الامر اما
والا
متطابقون كما قلت مع
تحالف الشعب تحالف اردوغان هو انهم في
واقي الامر الشق عن حزب الحركه القوميه
لهذا السبب لانه لم يبقى متمسكا بالعناصر
القوميه الاساسيه والا العقليه القوميه لا
تزال موجوده لديهم